[Music]
no one in Britain who is willing to work
will ever again suffer absolute want the
post-war welfare system may preventing
destitution the responsibility of the
state and only a scheme like this can
afford you with such high benefits come
on now it's worth it isn't it every
penny of it now a new welfare revolution
is underway shifting greater
responsibility back to the individual
and changing lives in the process
people are killing ourselves over this
you know why is this going on in this
line 18 special we speak to those
claiming universal credit the
professionals grappling with the system
and the new data that reveals its impact
on debt evictions and hunger hi my name
is Joe Cahill I'm calling from the
specialist welfare advice team at new
charter did you hey did you receive our
lottery Guardian universal credit No one
morning in March things changed in this
area of Greater Manchester the universal
credit rollout arrived in Tameside
the new Charter Housing Association
knows what that means of their tenants
already on the new system 85% are in
rent arrears with around 5,000 more of
their Tameside tenants now about to be
moved on to it they need to get prepared
we've identified who is going to be
affected and will go through a needs
assessment and will then identify
anything like if they've got there if
they've got no internet they've got no
passports things like that I'll go this
way
by design all new claimants will face a
minimum of five weeks without payment
but that could potentially be much
longer if they have problems completing
the online application process
and so rent arrears can build up and
with that comes the risk of eviction
Denise McIntyre fears that is exactly
what is going to happen to her she's a
grandmother and with serious respiratory
problems is unable to work but when
she's moved on to the new system she too
will face at least a month before her
claim is paid I will Rea the angle to
end up on the street with nothing I
really do
well advance loans are available the
fact she already has accumulated debts
means she doesn't want to take on more
did work but the government don't care
they don't listen to people they don't
and the offer from new charter to assist
with food parcels he's more upsetting
than reassuring oh I know what I'll do
I'll finish it before I get to the point
where I've got going out there is health
food you know there are people who are
you speaking to so today
yeah yeah but I couldn't go to Joe and
say look no I've got no food
I need adult food I couldn't do that
can't lower myself to do that he's that
sort of thing you're hearing a lot of
they are so proud and they don't want to
wring open ask for help
they've never they never have done and
obviously when we're now knocking on the
door and we're advising that we can help
and they see in this face-to-face
contact they wrote me not toward
universal credit merges a number of
separate benefits into one like a wage
is calculated on how much you've worked
and paid monthly in arrears not upfront
and to encourage people to manage their
own finances housing benefit is paid
direct to them but in practice that's
causing serious problems in a survey of
housing associations the National
Housing Federation found that across the
country 73 percent of tenants on
universal credit were in significant
rent arrears compared to 29% in areas
still using the previous benefit system
also provided to Sky News were interim
findings from a survey conducted by the
residential
Lord Association they found 62% of
private landlords are now unwilling to
rent to universal credit claimants and
amongst those landlords that are renting
to universal credit claimants almost a
third said they'd evicted a tenant on
the new benefit in the last 12 months in
more than three-quarters of those cases
this was as a result of rent arrears Joe
Beck manages 350 rental properties
across Greater Manchester and sees these
issues daily all of a sudden a large
amount of monies going into their
account and they're expected to make
sure that the rents paid every time
every month on time and common sense
tells you that should happen no problems
but no it doesn't dealing with the
fallout of benefit changes has changed
his job I'm not a letting agent I might
say that unlike business card but no
we're social workers were citizen Advice
bureaux for you know tenants like our
mother landlords were a crash sometimes
when they bring the kids it's oh no no
we're more than just letting agents and
you have to be you have to you have to
do that if you don't adapt if you don't
if you just black and white with it and
say you've not paid your rent you're
evicted and you might as well just close
up shop
the real revolutionary impact of
universal credit isn't its intention to
simplify the system or ensure that work
always pays more than benefits the
revolution is in the way it redefines
the very purpose of welfare to being to
tackle worklessness treating it as a
behavioral problem an attitude that the
system is designed to change
the government say the system is
succeeding in its aims with people
moving in to work more quickly and
staying in work for longer
Charlotte Hughes isn't persuaded for
four years she's held a weekly demo
outside Ashton Job Center giving out
food and advice to people she believes
are being uttered failed by the state as
long as the universal credit exists we
will still have to be here to pick up
the pieces all right
we see some horrible things and people
literally stabbing people we used to see
in the other day is committing suicide
you know police officers telling us that
you won't see this person anymore
because they committed suicide last week
I still care would I know about this
gentleman that I used to know every week
that I used to speak to you know and why
is this going on while we were filming
it a young man approached we'd been
sleeping rough come put your stuff down
another one got someone CUDA but you've
not yet for a long time have you so
we've got 19 year-old young men and
young women a homeless and they fall the
can get housing because there's no the
can't get housing because they've got to
have a shared room thing and it can't
get a shared room how can you come up
with a deposit for that and who do our
families I don't have a family this
gentleman doesn't have a family not got
an address I've not got a bank
I'm not even good idea you see they
expect people to have all those things
how can you get a bank coat without ID
you know how can they do how can I do
that it's just the impossible into
people like this lovely young man a
falling through the cracks of the system
right don't don't camp out in the middle
of town please you're going to be so
vulnerable
Ryan Abraham's is 19
not only has he been unable to find
homelessness support but when it comes
to benefits his circumstances mean he
cannot even access the system let alone
make a claim everywhere I go they told
me that I've been homeless for this long
and I've managed to keep myself alive
this long so me so I can last
that's all I can last a few more months
on the streets with and they don't they
just don't get back to you after that
I've got no phone
I've got no access to Internet I can
search jobs online I kept my CV printed
out because I've got not got the money
to do so I've not got any of the things
that you needed for a job I just but
I'll write a call from our lost
in nearby Oldham full universal credit
has been in place for more than a year
and the issues people here are facing
suggests there are more than just
teething problems a traumatic experience
in her past has left Joanne unable to
work now the renovation notices are
piling up she's already been transferred
off her previous benefits but is yet to
successfully set up a new claim weaning
rent hasn't been sent to her landlord in
months she's made homeless she could
lose the custody of her son be life has
been turned upside down I feel I feel
desperate I feel horrible and no one's
listening what kind of money are you
living off a weekend not a minute not 20
quid for food not know nothing I'm
getting off all my money's been stopped
so and the only reason why I've got food
at the minute is probably more the
people are killing ourselves over this
you know do you know what just don't
know per few deaths people because
they're in a race through the housing
the get evicted to kill themselves of
universal credit
but it's not just people who can't work
that are struggling even those in work
are finding it hard to make ends meet
they making it so difficult for single
moms Tonya is employed as a carer
to make universal credit meet her needs
and those of her four daughters she's
been told to work more hours but that
means additional childcare costs that
you can't afford
it's where the government says it's
making sure that you have all the
benefits no it's not no not at all
nothing
my worth man when is worse working than
before I feel like not working that's
all that's how it is I got more not
working another key indicator of the
impact of universal credit has been food
bank news new figures from the Trussell
trust show that on average food bank
usage in areas where universal credit
has been rolled out went up 52 percent
in the first 12 months of the new system
four times higher than in areas where
it's yet to be introduced and it's here
in the northwest
that food bank demand is highest with
nearly 200,000 parcels given out last
year across the region in the olden food
bank they've seen a major increase in
demand with people in work but on
universal credit now regularly among
those relying on handouts to survive
this is the fifth time that Frank's been
referred to the food bank just over a
year ago an injury prevented him from
working now despite being on universal
credits cannot afford to eat it feels as
though I've been persecuted I've worked
for 45 years I play I paid my taxes for
logic values my insurance policies and
now when we further down the line when I
need assistance they can only offer me
limited assistance and I don't think
that's right dead of starvation the
sheer volume of complaints about the
system has prompted some to urge the
government to pause the universal credit
rollout but that has not happened as a
result of pressures a number of changes
have been made to universal credit the
claim and hotline no longer has any
charges 18 to 21 year olds
are no longer exempt from the housing
allowance in some circumstances
landlords can have rent paid direct to
them and crucially the minimum wait
period between a claim and that first
benefit payment coming through its being
reduced from six weeks
to five the government say this shows
they are listening critics say it simply
shows the system isn't fit for purpose
in the end the question of whether
welfare is working depends on how you
define its purpose the government say
that work is the best form of welfare
and with record levels of employment
they suggest it must be succeeding in
its aims but if the purpose of welfare
is to ensure everyone both in and out of
work is prevented from going hungry or
losing the roof from over their heads
evidence is stacking up that something
is going seriously wrong